je me tourne vers jade Partouche qui est
arrivé en trainant des pieds ce matin à
la rédaction en disant je suis grosse je
suis grosse alors non c'est pas que vous
êtes gros vous dites vous avez grossi
depuis que vous faites la matinale de
LCI ce qui est mécaniquement normal
parce que les horaires sont décalés etc
mais globalement la population française
prend du poids le nombre de cas
d'obésité ashley a presque triplé en un
demi siècle près d'un adulte Français
sur deux en fait est en situation de
surpoids ou d'obésité augmente surtout
chez les jeunes Français les 18 34 ans
en cause l'alimentation et le manque
d'exercices alors pour changer les
habitudes alimentaires des initiatives
existent dans le détail les chiffres
montrent clairement un lien entre
surpoids et paupérisation ce sont les
plus précaires qui sont d'abord victimes
le sujet de l'obésité c'est d'abord le
sujet de la sédentarité et puis des
gamins devant les écrans quoi parce que
quand tu fais une génération qui a
commencé les écrans à 3 mois et demi qui
commence à avoir 25 ans et ben ça va
faire des ravages si les gens ne sont
pas capables de savoir ce qui est bon ce
qui est pas bon que bouger son cul au
lieu de rester devant un écran c'est
mieux que de prendre sa vie en main pour
faire attention c'est important moi
honnêtement je m'en fous je m'en fous je
fais du sport uniquement pour me
préparer pour Koh-Lanta ça fait 14 ans
que je m'inscris chaque année et 14 ans
je me prépare alors je peux vous assurer
que je suis prête allez maman
quand tu rentres de boulot le soir il
préfère ouvrir un surgelé plutôt que de
faire à bouffer quoi et que
l'organisation qui te permet de manger
des produits frais c'est à dire de
cuisiner le week-end de cuisiner quand
tu as du temps libre de faire des
petites parts pour en avoir toute la
semaine et ben ça c'est une organisation
qui est en perdent les gens quoi parce
que les gens ils veulent du temps libre
ils veulent des loisirs mais ils veulent
pas passer du temps à la cuisine pour
toute la semaine voilà nous avons un
projet assez assez excitant avec la
ligue contre l'obésité c'est d'envoyer
des diététiciennes à domicile pour aider
les familles à risque en sortie de de
centre de pédiatrie d'obésité
pour expliquer comment faire un repas
aller faire les courses et essayer
d'aider les gens à domicile l'assiste à
la permanent moi ça me gonfle
c'est chacun doit savoir quand même au
bout d'un moment tu es responsable de
savoir ce que tu bouffes si tu as envie
d'aller au McDo tous les jours mais sois
malade j'en ai rien à [__] avant
envoyer c'était un plaisir en se disant
on va au McDo par plaisir alors que là
on va des fois au McDo par nécessité ça
me revient moins cher tout simplement
prendre un menu enfant à 4 euros et au
final vous avez une boisson des frites
et un sandwich et vous allez être sûr
qu'entre guillemets vous ayez un repas
complet
ou c'est assistanat
assistanat à l'assistana on répond par
une taxe à la taxe
franchement moi ça me fatigue
sympathique parce que tu caricature on
parait juste caricature
Célia les aventuriers de la tribu jaune
ont décidé de vous éliminer et leur
sentence est irrévocable
c'était vraiment l'événement du jour
qu'est-ce que Poutine à côté d'Emmanuel
Macron qui se balade au milieu de la
bidoche
tire complètement tout cela est encore
un peu flou priorité au direct nous
suivons ce matin Emmanuel Macron au
marché de Rungis la guerre c'est bien
mieux le président qui se balade au
milieu des carcasses une visite pour
être au contact de la France qui se lève
tôt je bossais mon imitation c'est pas
mal quand on commence le boulot
faut que le travail continue de payer
davantage Emmanuel Macron qui profite de
cet échange pour interpeller la députée
insoumise du Val-de-Marne Rachel kéké
qui l'accompagne au nom de la tradition
républicaine
et de voir mais vive les fous vive les
fous on a assisté à un point
philosophique qui a pas trop retenu
l'attention du président
on s'en bat les couilles on s'en bat les
couilles on s'en bat les couilles
président et au Pavillon des fromages
midi marine Lançon est actuellement au
Pavillon volaille il est tout cassé ou
petit déjeuner ou plutôt au bistrot en
heure de Rungis ils nous ont vraiment
tenu au courant minute par minute de sa
déambulation y compris quand c'était pas
forcément limpide Emmanuel Macron est au
fond de cette image
si vous arrivez à le voir sur cette
image écrivez nous perso on cherche
encore l'accusé le chef étoilé Philippe
Etchebest le motif il a voulu changer la
recette c'est cette petite fraise qui a
déclenché la polémique il explique
tranquillement sur sa chaîne Youtube
comment préparer une quiche lorraine
revisitée je prépare du fromage j'ai mis
du comté et j'entends déjà les puristes
crier au scandale parce qu'on ne met pas
de fromage dans la quiche lorraine et
ben moi j'en mets parce que j'aime bien
le fromage j'en mets moi aussi j'aime
bien le fromage et bah c'est pas bien
c'est pas bien du tout je suis curieux
de toute façon
l'alimentation du monde et effectivement
la pizza hawaïenne pourquoi pas
un manque d'éducation
ça va te pousser à quoi ça va pipi à
côté de tes toilettes juste pour passer
à la curiosité ça peut te mener à tous
les excès fais attention hein même
Philippe Etchebest ce que ce n'est pas
la recette originale mais trop tard
300000 vues plus tard cette petite
phrase au milieu des 12 minutes de vidéo
a provoqué un torrent de réaction à
l'est de la France on ne rigole pas avec
la recette de la quiche lorraine pas de
brisée ou feuilletée des œufs crème
fraîche lardons rien d'autre avec du
fromage n'est pas une quiche lorraine
juste une quiche pour Jérôme mais où
va-t-on il n'y a plus de tradition ne
décolère pas Hélène ça c'était sur
Twitter et là-bas
ça reste quand même une bouillie avec
des lardons quoi c'est pas non plus
formidable avec quiche lorraine pardon
mais
bon ça c'est un on n'est pas en train de
parler d'un truc extraordinaire non plus
attention simplement
non non vous allez pas parler tout le
temps parce que moi non non non
terrible ils sont terribles bon c'est
mieux quand vous parlez pas en fait
c'est pas facile de partir au bout de
trois jours après avoir attendu 14 ans
mais j'ai quand même de la chance
d'avoir si ce que c'était cette aventure
m'a apporté un petit morceau de mon rêve
c'est mieux que rien